les premières odeurs de ces primaires
socialistes sont particulièrement
décevant puisque gibault confirmant les
boules puantes comme ça on se demande
d'où ça vient
à qui ça sert on espère que ça va
s'arrêter parce que si ça ne s'arrête
pas c'est la primaire qui est en danger
pardonnez moi cette se moque on va
reprendre et qui est entendu à gauche
par un cadre dirigeant
ça la fout mal qu'est ce que vous pensez
vous du spectacle entre guillemets qui
est donné avec ces ça la fout
mal
et moi ça me choque vous êtes bien un
jour de vos cotisations au psg oui oui
maintenant s'ils n'ont pas de candidats
du nouveau votre candidature je ne goûte
pas trop de ce type de chicaya arnaud
montebourg et vincent peillon sont des
militants socialistes qui ont toujours
été
comment dirais-je correct il démenti
formellement j'ai apporté les éléments
nous n'avons pas de sujet non moi je
veux être moi mentalement juste que nous
avons est ce que vous avez demandé à
françois fillon s'il voulait être le
benoît hamon le budget du ps pour cette
élection
il donne à 50000 euros à chaque candidat
la somme ici en actes et 25 millions
voilà on a claqué la moitié du budget
qui nous donnent le parti socialiste
rien dans ce meeting j'aspire à être
benoît hamon est pas françois fillon je
lui reconnais un mérite à mérite d'avoir
incarner une droite sans ambiguïté je
connais parfaitement les effets pervers
du 43 je suis très lucide et puis j'ai
appris et puis on prend du recul dans la
société de la participation dans
laquelle nous vivons
son utilisation est devenu dépassé et
elle apparaît comme brutal vous êtes
surpris mais je me sens
bah oui parce que je viens de là du tout
sa position bah écoute et l'exercice du
pouvoir et je les fais avec le premier
ministre appelé manuel valls et qui a vu
des 49 3 la proposition de supprimer le
49-3 de la part de l'ancien premier
ministre aurait dû être précédée d'une
suppression du 49-3 dans les pratiques
et l'exercice du pouvoir
il ya donc une forme d'incohérence entre
les paroles et les actes
qu'est ce que le jour où on a besoin du
49-3 sur un budget on a connu ça à
droite à l'audition du jeu propose tout
simplement qu'on puisse l'utiliser que
pour les textes budgétaires parce que
une nation a besoin d'un budget et qu'on
supprime tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
moi je propose 1 49 3 citoyens c'est à
dire la possibilité pour un pour cent
des électeurs inscrits sur les listes
électorales par pétition d'obliger à ce
qu'un texte de loi
quand ils sont donc quatre cent
cinquante mille c'est ça un pour cent
des citoyens inscrits sur liste
électorale d'obliger à ce qu'un texte de
loi voté à l'assemblée passe par
référendum
marc est toujours une bonne idée de
reconnaître ses fautes et ses erreurs et
moi je me réjouis que manuel valls
avance dans cette direction
s'il continue ainsi sa campagne il va
bientôt finir par nous dire qu'il faut
évacuer notre dame des landes
pourquoi ne la pâte il faire
il va finir par nous dire qu'il faut à
redresser les comptes de la sécurité
sociale faire baisser le chômage
au fond ils sont eux mêmes les propres
juges du bilan de ce quinquennat
[Musique]